now to germany where an initially slow
vaccine rollout is picking up pace
chancellor angela merkel has
raised the hope that by june anyone who
wants to make an appointment
will for a jab will be able to do so her
comments came
after a meeting with the 16 state
premiers to discuss the vaccination
drive
chancellor angela merkel dubbed a
meeting of hope
the situation in germany remains serious
with daily covet 19 cases
still alarmingly high and the number of
coronavirus patients in intensive care
still growing but the vaccination drive
is picking up speed
so much so that germany may soon be able
to offer vaccines to everyone
not only those at high risk
on the whole we expect the people in the
high priority group
will be vaccinated by the end of may
that means that depending on how many
vaccine doses we get
we can abandon the priority list as of
june at the latest
this does not mean that everyone can be
vaccinated immediately
but that everyone can make an
appointment
after a slow start during the first few
months of the year
now around 23 percent of germany's
population has received the first dose
that's thanks to an increase in
deliveries more reliable supply chains
and family doctors now also
administering the shot
with more and more people vaccinated the
debate on whether they should enjoy more
freedom from restrictions
is also mounting chancellor merkel said
the government is preparing legislation
to ease some measures
those who have been fully vaccinated or
those who have recovered from covet 19
should be exempted from having to get
tested to go to non-essential shops
or from quarantining after returning
from abroad
they would still however have to
continue following mask
and social distancing roles
i think that's unfair a more nuanced
solution must be found
it is absolutely clear to me that people
who have been vaccinated must get their
basic rights back
it's not a question of whether they get
special rights but that they can live
normally again
i think it's good but it's a pity that
it's not my turn yet
but her turn may not be far off
chancellor mackel's promise to offer
every adult in germany a vaccine by the
end of the summer
seemed impossible to many only a few
weeks ago
now hopes are high that her pledge will
be met
and for more on this i'm joined by dws
ania shaffer north good morning to you
anya so why has chancellor angela merkel
and the leaders of germany's
16 states not been able to agree on what
freedoms
vaccinated people could have
well christine in the last few months of
this pandemic we've seen
lots of these meetings between the
chancellor and the state leaders
that have dragged on long into the night
where there's been lots of controversy
debate
it's been incredibly hard to find
consensus
and it was almost like this time round
they decided this was going to be a
meeting with some
good news and they put the difficult
decisions off
and it was clear from the start that the
most difficult decision of this
that was on the agenda at this meeting
was the
you know reinstituting basic rights for
those who've been vaccinated
and and it seems that decision has just
been pushed further down the road really
and also bear in mind that here in
germany a national lockdown law
only just came into effect on saturday
infection rates are still
inching up at the moment and and of
course
if you look at the figures we just saw
it there only just over seven percent of
people have actually been fully
vaccinated
and so it does seem still pretty early
to be making those decisions about
what rights they should be getting back
right
but this is happening as we're saying
that this the vaccination drive is
kicking into gear
won't the growing amount of vaccinated
people now increase the pressure
for them to be granted more freedoms
well yes and no really of course as more
and more people are vaccinated
and there's more demand for them to get
their rights back and the economy needs
it badly too of course
and but um it also makes it easier in a
way of course you have more people
vaccinated you have more support
uh for the you know for giving them
their rights back
and and it also there's an argument that
it might persuade those who've been
reluctant to get vaccinated
and to get finally get their job and but
also this could all be a very short
discussion in a way because
if the vaccination drive really does go
ahead as quickly as merkel has now
promised
and everyone can you know apply to get a
vaccine come june
then we may have reached herd immunity
sooner than we think
and may all be able to lead normal lives
again all right that's any sharpening
reporting for us here thank you anya
you